Oh,
we the only living things in the entire universe.
The observable universe is about 90 billion light years in diameter.
There are at least 100 billion galaxies,
each with 100 to 1000 billion stars.
Recently we've learned the planets are very common to,
and there are probably trillions and trillions of habitable planets in the
universe,
which means there should be lots of opportunity for life to develop and exist,
right?
But where is it?
Shouldn't the universe be teaming with spaceships?
Let's take a step back.
Even if there are alien civilizations and other galaxies,
there's no way we'll ever know about them.
Basically everything outside of our direct galactic neighborhood,
the so called local group is pretty much out of our reach forever because of the
expansion of the universe.
Even if we had really fast space ships,
it would literally take billions of years to reach these places traveling
through the emptiest areas in the universe.
So let's focus on the Milky Way.
The Milky Way is our home galaxy.
It consists of up to 400 billion stars.
That's a lot of stars,
roughly 10,000 for every grain of sand on earth.
There are about 20 billion sunlight stars in the Milky Way,
and estimates suggest that a fifth of them have an earth sized planet in its
habitable zone.
The area with conditions that enable life to exist.
If only 0.1% of those planets harbored life,
there would be 1 million planets with life in the Milky Way,
but wait,
there's more.
The Milky Way,
it's about 13 billion years old.
In the beginning,
it would not have been a good piece for life because things exploded a lot,
but after one to 2 billion years,
the first habitable planets were born on earth is only 4 billion years old,
so there have probably been trillions of chances for life to develop on other
planets in the past.
If only a single one of them had developed into a space traveling super
civilization,
we would have noticed by now.
What would such a civilization look like?
There are three categories.
A type one civilization would be able to access the whole energy available on
its planet.
In case you're wondering,
we're currently around 0.73 on the scale and we should reach type one sometime
in the next couple of hundred years.
Type two would be a civilization capable of harnessing all of the energy of it's
Homestar.
This would require some serious science fiction,
but it is doable in principle concepts like the Dyson sphere,
a giant complex surrounding the sun would be conceivable.
Time three is a civilization that basically controls its whole galaxy and it's
energy.
An alien race that this advanced would probably be good like to us,
but why should we be able to see such an alien civilization in the first place?
If we were to build generation space ships that could sustain a population for
around 1000 years,
we could colonize the whole galaxy into million years.
Sounds like a long time,
but remember the milky way is huge.
So if it takes a couple of million years to colonize the entire galaxy and there
are possibly millions,
if not billions of pallets that sustained knife in the Milky Way and these other
life forms have had considerably more time than we've had then.
Where are all the aliens?
This is the Fermi paradox and nobody has nods to it,
but we do have some ideas,
but let's talk about filters or filter in this context represents a barrier that
is really hard for life to overcome or they come in various degrees of scary
one.
There are great filters and we have passed them.
Maybe it is way harder for complex life to develop than we think.
The process allowing life to begin hasn't yet been completely figured out and
the conditions required maybe ready complicated.
Maybe in the past the universe was way more hostile and only recently have
things cooled down to make complex life possible.
This would also mean that we may be unique or at least one of the first,
if not the first civilization in the entire universe to there are great filters
and they are ahead of us.
This one would be ready,
ready,
bad.
Maybe life on our level exists everywhere in the universe,
but it gets destroyed when it reaches a certain point of point that lies ahead
of us.
For example,
awesome future technology exists,
but when activated,
it destroys the planet.
The last words of every advanced civilization would be this new device will
solve all of our problems once I pushed this button.
If this is true,
then we are closer to the end than the beginning of human existence or maybe
there is an ancient type three civilizations that monitors the universe and once
a civilization is advanced enough,
it gets eliminated in an instant.
Maybe there is something out there that it will be better not to discover.
There is no way for us to know one final thought.
Maybe we're alone right now.
We have no evidence that there's any life besides us.
Nothing.
The universe appears to be empty and debt.
No one's sending us messages,
no one answering our calls.
We may be completely alone,
trapped on a tiny,
moist Mudville in an eternal universe.
Does that false scare you?
If it does,
you'll having the correct emotional reaction.
If we let life on this planet die,
perhaps there will be no life left in the universe.
Life will be gone maybe forever.
If this is the case,
we just have to venture to the stars and become the first type three
civilizations to keep the delicate flame of life existing and to spread it until
the universe breathes its final breath and vanishes into oblivion.
The Universe is too beautiful not to be experienced by someone.
This video was made possible by your support.
It takes at least 200 hours to make one of our videos and thanks to your
contributions on Patrion.
We are slowly able to do more and more of them.
If you want to help us out and get your own personal bird,
for example,
check out the Patrion page.